and Obama's White House by the way it
was a revolving door for celebrities you
remember the policy summit he had with
rappers common busta rhymes and Ludacris
about criminal justice reform well you
probably don't because the left-wing
media didn't freak out over it like they
did when one guy goes through the oval
office yesterday Kanye West joining us
now with reaction double-standard
extraordinaire here of course Howie
Kurtz
Howie of course media buzz great show on
the weekends on Fox Howie this is wild
because I remember when Kanye came and
he did his poetry slam at the White
House and I mean I could being truth be
told I actually kind of you know laughed
at it because I thought the poem was
really bad that he did on stage but
Obama was just really at ease with
celebrities and obviously they loved him
no one cared
Obama celebrities Obama's rappers they
were they had the approved ideology so
it was okay the me to kind of celebrate
it look what Kanye did in the Oval
Office it is fine for critics to say it
was weird it was strange it was bizarre
even Donald Trump seemed kind of
speechless for a moment but the brutal
nature of some of this criticism as a
result is clearly driven by ideology
when Kanye West was talking about George
Bush doesn't care about black people oh
well I criticize them for that yeah but
a lot of these liberals said oh he's a
really cool dude and now because he's
wearing the red hat and he's embracing
Donald Trump he must be loco what are
the chances like next week he'll be
wearing like a Cory Booker hat is there
any chance
what's her alright Jackie Speier when I
play this for you Howie congresswoman
from California said this about Kanye
and his mental health it was a
combination of stream of consciousness I
felt like I was sitting in on a
psychiatric visit and a commercial for
Donald Trump
it wasn't newsworthy certainly but I
would suggest that the president should
maybe curtail these kinds of engagements
well how a 36 percent approval rasmussen
among african-americans that's double
from last year same poll it seems like
they're more worried about Conda Kayne
effect on the midterm elections than
they are about Kanye's mental health
well here we see the mental health issue
being brought up again and you know in
addition to the congresswoman it seems
like
harshest criticism is coming from other
african-americans you played Don Lemon
dragon County Hays late mother into it
CNN contributor Tara set Meyer said he
was a token Negro I heard that phrase in
in decades what it's rooted in the
notion that if a black person black
people who are for somebody like Donald
Trump they can't know what they're
talking about they're completely
misinformed they're they have serious
issues and all of that and that you know
they no longer have a monopoly and so
the piling on here against Kanye West
there's an entertaining guy who as you
say Bob we don't know all that much
about politics more so than who Matt
Damon yeah and he went there to talk
about actually a serious issue like his
wife Kim Kardashian did so the freak out
is just so over the top that I think it
can only be written off as ideological
opposition to a guy who thinks a little
differently
we'll be watching media buzz this
weekend Howie thanks so much for being
with us